In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinoxadion for September 9th, on which we commemorate, the holy and
great martyr Severian of Sebastian.
Saint Severian was an eminent citizen of Sebastian in the days of the Emperor Licinius in the
years 307 through 324.
An imperial counselor by rank, he was highly esteemed for his virtue and for his faith in Christ.
When Lysius, the new provincial governor, heard of the many pagans converted by his word
and virtue, and of how forward he had been in encouraging the forty martyrs commemorated
on the 9th of March.
He decided to submit him to interrogation, but before the soldiers could find him, Severian
presented himself of his own accord at the tribunal.
His steadfastness and unshakable patience under torture amazed Lysius, covered in wounds
and dragged to the center of the city to be thrown into prison.
Severian ceaselessly urged the crowd following him to be faithful to Christ and to persevere
in well-doing.
Five days later, with his flesh torn by iron claws and huge stones hanging from his neck
and from his feet, he was hoisted to the top of a wall and suspended by his belt.
All were astounded at his endurance, as hour after hour he continued to confess the name
of Christ until he joyfully gave up his spirit to God.
The wife of one of Severian's servants was among those who went to his burial.
Her husband had just died, and in her distress she turned to his body with the words,
get up dear husband so that we may go to meet our master.
No sooner had she spoken than the dead man got up and ran to assist at the martyr's funeral.
He lived on for another fifteen years.
Since the Christians could not decide whether to bury the martyr, they willved a crown of
flowers and placed it on his body and waited for a sign from heaven, whereupon a great eagle
appeared in the sky, grasped the crown in its talons and slowly flew off to a nearby forest
or had dropped it and was no more seen.
The Christians buried Severian where the crown of flowers lay.
His tomb became the source of miracles and the servant who had been raised from the dead
tended it until the end of his days.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.